eight news now viewer reached out to say
how much he appreciated the national
guard
you may have seen soldiers if you've
been to a covet testing site throughout
the valley
this thanksgiving eve vanessa murphy
introduces you to a group the viewer
and likely many others are thankful for
nevada is home for these national
guardsmen we're
neighbors helping neighbors for sergeant
thomas jackabellis the call for duty
came in
april to provide help during the kovit
19 pandemic
this is a very unique deployment i've
been in afghanistan that was much
different because i'm away from family
while he is grateful he is home he also
acknowledges the risk of
being on the front line honestly the
hardest part is i don't want to get sick
and get someone in my family sick that's
the hardest part for me personally
but again just the reassurance having
the support of your your fellow soldiers
as well as your family at night it makes
a lot different than just relying on a
letter coming in the mail every month
this is the largest call up of the
national guard in this state's history
i've told our soldiers and airmen is
that they are part of history
in their response to this pandemic it's
hard to prepare for something that no
one is ready for
so everything is constantly changing
constantly evolving every day
they say news of a vaccine boosted
morale during this mission
showing light at the end of the tunnel
for all of us
vanessa murphy 8 news now colonel troy
armstrong says the call started with
more than 1100 soldiers and airmen that
number is reduced to more than 400 about
half up north
and half right here in southern nevada